Let's go next to Justin from
Orange County, California.
Just to carry high, yes, I can. Hi, David.
I was just wondering what your thoughts
were on Joe Biden's town hall yesterday and
saying that he wasn't planning on canceling
the fifty thousand dollars in student debt.
Yeah, so we talked about this a little bit on
a livestream earlier this week. I appreciated
that he was just being direct in his answer.
Biden never ran on canceling 50000 in student
debt. He's not pretending like he's going to.
And he just said, I'm not going to do it. Now,
some of the some of the reasoning he gave about,
well, we want to do K through 12 stuff or this
or that. I mean, you can walk and chew gum at
the same time. If he was determined to cancel
50 K and K through 12 funding and improvements,
I think he would be able to do it. So I
think that some of the reasoning after the
fact wasn't wasn't great, but I was refreshed.
As I said before, you know, if Trump were to be
asked, will you do 50 K, Trump would say, well,
you know, we're thinking about a lot of different
things, but you've got to remember that college
has really become indoctrination. And for a lot
of people, they go to college, they come out, and
all of a sudden they believe all these horrible
things like Cryin Chuck, Chuck and Crazy Nancy are
good people. And we got to vote for Crazy Bernie.
So I'm not so big on college necessarily, although
I went to Upend and got the best grades and,
you know, I did so great at the top school and
my kids went there. But, you know, 10000, 20000,
50000, these are numbers and we're looking at them
very strongly and we'll come back to that in some
period of time. Like that would be Trump's answer,
right? Biden said, yeah, no, I'm not going to do
the 50 K, and that's direct. It's consistent
with what he said all along. He's not bamboozling
anybody. So I appreciated the directness, the
honesty. I wish his policy were a different one.
So you stand behind the cancelation.
Personally, I don't know about full cancelation,
I have my doubts about full cancelation of all
student debt. I do think that the the reason I'm
more partial to partial would be that we have
a situation where, sure, college is optional,
but increasingly with more and more jobs requiring
college and the cost of college going up and up
and up, it's it's not totally clean to me. Just
to say if you choose to go to college, then you
should you know, it just that's it. You've chosen
and you should be responsible for the full debt
at the same time to say everybody just gets
a full cancelation of all student debt.
I'm not there. So I'm for partial cancelation and
I've seen a number of different plans that would
structure it in different ways. I don't know
exactly whether I would put a dollar amount on
it or a percentage or how I would do it.
OK, that makes sense. Thank you, David.
All right, my pleasure. A lot of meaty,
substantive questions coming in today.